os la politique c'est on le sait un de
vos thèmes de vos sujets de prédilection
mais dans le spectacle vous tapez
désormais beaucoup plus sur la gauche et
même quasiment essentiellement sur la
gauche il a-t-il des membres du
gouvernement qui ont eu le courage de
venir vous
voir je cherche apparemment pas beaucoup
domin troscan mais en tant que Marie
d'Anne Sinclair qui est ma copine Martin
auri non Martin au non je pense qu'elle
a un agenda très
chargé
vous
malade vous savez c'est pas ou mais il
all au spectacleme c'est ce que vous
dites dans votre spectacle pas vrai
c'est c'est c'est le figurant qui qui
double Mister Bean d'habitude qui qui
qui est là Mister Bean il viendra
peut-être mais mais je vaement n'est pas
sorti l'opération n'a pas eu lieu vous
savez donc c'est pas lui gu dans
l'actualité de ce matin est-ce qu'il y
aurait un thème qui pourrait vous
inspirer pour le sketch de ce soir par
exemple non mais je regardais par
exemple la Corse la Corse c'est pas
c'est je dire un pays c'est pas un
département qui m'est tout à fait
étranger c'est c'est je le dis parfois
pour rire c'est mon Algérie de
rechange bon c'est la même végétation
c'est la même c'est même aussi un peu le
même tempérament j'aime je m'empresse de
dire que j'aime bien les Corses moi il
faut pas globaliser il y a a tête de con
parmi les cors mais il y a aussi des
gens très bien et je pense que de droit
et tout ce qu'on veut faire en Corse et
bel et bon mais il faut donner l'exemple
et il faut qu'à Paris aussi l'état de
droit règne et que certaines affaires
soient réglées sinon les Corses comme
les jeunes des cités comme tant d'autres
se diront Ben qui commence déjà par
régler le problème du président du
Conseil constitutionnel ou du président
de la République on parlera des jeunes
en tout cas tout à l'heure l'actualité
internationale l'Italie est encore sous
le choc de l'acquitement du pilote
américain accusé d'être à l'origine de
de la mort d'une vingtaine de personnes
il y a tout juste un an l'avion de ce
pilote avait sectionné un câble de
téléphérique dans une station des de ski
des Alpes italiennes jugé par une cour
martiale américaine l'aviateur a donc
été acquitté Philippe
berias embarrassé mais libre quelques
minutes après le verdict Richard Ashby
est venu dire publiquement qu'il pensait
aux familles des victimes et qu'il
priait pour
elle après 2 jours de procès devant le
tribunal militaire de quand le jeune aux
États-Unis le capitaine des Marines
Richard asby a été innocenté le jury a
retenu tous les arguments de la défense
pour l'armée américaine le drame de
cavalaise ne serait qu'un accident si
l'avion des Marines s' tranché le câble
du téléphérique le 3 février 1998 c'est
parce que les cartes aériennes étaient
imprécises et parce que l'altimètre
était défectueux les familles des 20
victimes elles sont
choquées j'ai enterré mon mari il y a un
an
aujourd'hui c'est comme un deuxième
enterrement à cavalz dans les Dolomites
italiennes l'émotion est à son comble
ici on avait longtemps réclamé que le
procès des Marines se tienne en Italie
pour le maire du village l'argument
selon lequel les cartes aériennes
étaient imprécis est une mauvaise
excuse vous savez ces villages qui ont
été survolés à moins de 100 m du sol ils
existaient déjà bien avant la découverte
de l'Amérique en visite aux États-Unis
Massimo dalema le président du Conseil
italien s dit déconcerté par ce jugement
il demandera des explications
aujourd'hui à Bill Clinton entre les
États-Unis et l'Italie la polémique
contient déjà les ferments d'une crise
diplomatique en Turquie preuve de la
tension qui existe dans ce pays depuis
l'arrestation du leader kurde abdouah
chchalan un nouvel attentat a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à une centaine de kilomètres
nord-est d'Ankara trois personnes ont
été tuées 10 autres blessés dont le
gouverneur de la province de kankiri cet
attentat la voiture piégée intervient
alors que le PKK le Parti des
travailleurs du Kurdistan vient
d'annoncer une intensification de la
guerre contre la Turquie la Sierra
leéone est un petit pays d'Afrique de
l'Ouest secoué depuis des mois par des
affrontements sanglants entre les
rebelles et le régime légitime des
affrontements auquel une force
d'intervention ouestaricaine était
censée mettre fin or d'après un rapport
remis à l'ONU cette force d'intervention
appelée Ecomog se serait rendu coupable
de mauvais traitement sur des civils y
compris des enfants des enfants qui
avaient été enrollés de force par les
rebelles qui les avaient maltraité des
enfants qui sont aujourd'hui pour
chassés violemment par ceux qui devaient
donc pacifier le pays commentaire Anne
poncinet c'est un ancien hôtel
transformé en centre d'accueil un
endroit enfin presque normal pour ses
enfants rescapés de la guerre Moïse en
t-shirt bleu a été enrôlé de force par
les soldats rebelles difficile d'en
savoir plus il ne parle pas ou
plus est-ce qu'il parle
Moïse non il ne parle pas il ne parle
plus
parce qu'il était dans le camp des
rebelles Moïse a été arrêté par les
soldats de
l'omog des Nigériens qui ont agi comme
s'il n'avaent pas vu qu'il s'agissait
d'un
enfant Moïse n'est pas le seul au cours
de leur attaque de frit en janvier les
rebelles ont enrôé de force 300
enfants ils arrêtent les gens les
rassemblent il nous apprennent à tirer
ils nous font marcher longtemps et nous
apprennent à
espionner de la guerre qu' a côtoyé de
si près Moïse gardera des traumatismes
difficile à prendre en charge à freown
même si aujourd'hui les combats se sont
calm oui il semble traumatisé mais il
n'est pas en bonne santé nous allons
l'amener à l'hôpital pour comprendre ce
qu'il a pas de médecin ici non les
meilleurs docteurs ont quitté le pays
depuis longtemp
à Freetown la chasse aux rebelles se
poursuit la population est fouillée à la
recherche de traces de port d'armes les
enfants n'y échappe
pas privé d'innocence ils sont devenus
suspects c'est dans un climat
apparemment plus serein que les
ministres de l'Agriculture des 15 ont
repris les négociations ce matin sur la
réforme de la PAC si leurs relations
sont plus détendu entre allemand et
français il reste beaucoup d'obstacles à
franchir avant d'aboutir à un compromis
sur le budjet
reportage à Bruxelles Pascal golom
jean-jacqu
logarec qu'on se le dise le couple
franco-allemand va beaucoup mieux fin
les bouderies les deux ministres aiment
à dialoguer devant les caméras le ton se
détend mais cela ne suffit pas pour
régler tous les problèmes moin de là les
projections budgétaires remises au
ministre hier soir au dîner par le
commissaire européen prouent que le
chemin à parcourir est encore long ces
projections prennent en compte les
demandes spécifiques de chaque pays des
demandes qui sies étaient fa ferait
exploser le budget agricole prené par
les 15 chefs d'État à petterberg
vendredi dernier 260 milliards de francs
par an c'est l'objectif soit sur la
période
2000-2006 la somme rondelet de 2000
milliards de francs le dépassement que
prévoit la commission s'élèverait sur
cette même période à près de 163
milliards de francs et la proposition
française de réduire les aides directes
versé aux agriculteurs de 3 % chaque
année ne résoutrait rien ce n'est pas 3
mais 15 % de réduction qui serait
nécessaire pour que le budget de la PAC
reste dans les limites fixées bien sûr
il ne s'agit que de projection au cours
de la réunion de ce matin chaque
délégation doit en tout cas rappeler ses
priorités mais c'est mardi seulement que
les 15 ministres entreront dans le
détail du budget une belle querelle de
chiffres en perspective Lionel Jospin a
estimé ce matin qu'en ce qui concerne la
réforme de la PAC le climat est meilleur
mais que rien n'est encore fait le
premier ministre s'exprimait au cours de
sa visite du salon de l'agriculture pour
Lionel Jospin le comité d'accueil était
beaucoup plus cordial que pour Dominique
wanet qui a été vous le savez fortement
chuté hier par les agriculteurs Laurent
him
chaccord Lionel Jospin a bien failli
être en retard au
rendez-vous en fait un coup de fil
urgent à
donnerélé oui
onhe chaussur de DA noir veste marron et
cravate àortie le Premier ministre
endosser le costume du parfait gentleman
farmer pour se rendre au salon à l'heure
où Jean glaven défend à Bruxelles la
position française sur l'épineuse
question de la réforme de la Politique
Agricole Commune le Premier ministre
sacrifiait lui au folklore de la grande
ferme parisienne des dégustations qui
s'enchaînent la noix de
coco jambon de
payst qui a été notre souci
de je vais pas avoir besoin de déjeuner
à midi je pense mais surtout des
agriculteurs qu'il faut rassurer ren est
fait he j'avais Jean glavani juste avant
de rentrer dans le salon là alors j'ai
eu j'ai eu Gavan au téléphone ce matin
on l'a compris ce matin Lionel Jospin
est porteur des dernières nouvelles de
Bruxelles il onis le contact je pense
que la France n'est pas isolée dans la
discussion agricole parce que justement
elle défend une politique à mon sens
cohérente le climat est donc meilleur
mais rien n'est fait donc nous devons
être attentif et vigilant et et défendre
cette conception de l'agriculture dont
je parlais tout à l'heure la ronde des
hommes politiques va se poursuivre cet
après-midi et tout le weekend avec
l'avenue de Jacques Chirac dimanche qui
refermera cette édition du Salon de
l'Agriculture si vous voyez pas la vache
c'est pas que là c'est grave mon avis
c'est un métier difficile la politique
n'est-ce pas guos he mon Dieu qui on le
plus la vache ou Lionel Jospin mais il
est pas dans son emploi c'est pour
Chirac ce qu' fait là alors on va passer
à l'actualité sociale noter que le
comité d'entreprise des chantiers naval
du Havre n'a pas pu se tenir ce matin
cette réunion qui devait annoncer le
plan de fermeture dans l'entreprise a
été reporté par la direction qui a
trouvé l'entrée des chantiers cadenassés
par des manifestants s'opposant au
licenciement je vous rappelle que ces
chantiers qui doiv fermer en octobre
2000 emploie actuellement plus de 1100
personnes et puis les activités dans la
mine de charbon de Gardane devrait
reprendre normalement dans la journée
après 3 semaines d'occupation les
salariés d'une société de sousraitance
sont parvenus à un accord avec la
direction de la mine cet accord garantit
la pérenité de leur emploi jusqu'en août
2000 dossier de ce journal alors que
Claude Allègre vient de présenter les
grandes lignes de ce que devrait être
les lycées français au 21e siècle nous
avons choisi de nous arrêter sur deux
façons d'appréhender les questions de
violence et de discipline le premier
exemple nous vient de jarni en Meur
etmosel où le principal du collège a
décidé de renvoyer temporairement chez
eux les élèves de 3e qui n'ont pas fait
leur devoir une mesure radicale qui est
apparemment efficace reportage sur place
Jérôme Soulard Sylvain gtier c'est un
collège tout à fait ordinaire planté
dans la paisible campagne Lorine ni
incibilité ni violence particulière
juste quelques élèves de mauvais
exemples qui oublient un peu trop
souvent de faire leur
devoir celui qui veut travailler il
travaille celui qui veut pas il
travaille pas ça lu retomber la fin de
l'année mais c'est tout chacunit ce qu'
ve
JEP décidé de remettre un peu d'harmonie
dans le travail de ses élèves
l'avertissement a été envoyé aux
familles dorén avant tout manquement
d'un élève sera sanctionné par une
exclusion temporaire la convocation
immédiate des parents qui devront
prendre en charge leur enfant une heure
de colle à la maison pour faire ses
devoirs en famille avant de réintégrer
le collège il s'agit surtout de montrer
aux familles quel est leur rôle elles
ont un rôle important à jouer bon
l'école en face de de de classe
hétérogène a inventé la pédagogie
différenciée a
inventé tout toutes sortes de
dispositifs destinés à venir en aide aux
élèves en difficulté mais si on nobtient
pas à un moment donné une démarche de
l'élève qui consiste à comprendre que
pour réussir il faut fournir un travail
je crois qu'on est à côté de l'objectif
qu'on s'est fixé responsabiliser les
élèves mais également les parents dans
l'ensemble ils ont d'ailleurs plutôt
bien accueilli cette nouvelle mesure ils
s'impliquent dans le travail de leur
enfant je trouve que c'est bien pu en
plus il y a un phénomène de conseil les
enseignants ou l'équipe éducatif peut
les conseiller en leur disant faut faire
comme si comme ça et certains parents
trouvent que c'est bien quoi quant aux
délégués de classe de 3e ils souhaitent
déjà que cette mesure qu'ils sont les
seuls à subir soit étendu aux autres
classes moi je pense que comme les
troisèmes sont punis par cette méthode
il faudrait que les autres classes aussi
parce que les systèmes qui viennent
d'entrer au collège ils ont commencé à
pas travailler et si on leur metaz la
méthode tout de suite et ben ben il
commencerait à travailler il prendra il
prendrait pas de mauvaises habitudes
jusqu'en 3e puis il y a une amélioration
dans notre classe qui qui montre que ça
a bien marché parce que il y avait des
élèves qui faisaient jamais leur boulot
maintenant ils le font tout le temps une
mesure toute simple qui respecte les
droits des élèves mais rappelle les
règles et les devoirs élémentaires de la
vie d'un
collégien alors le deuxème exemple nous
amène ce matin au lycée professionnel
turgo à roubé un lycée qui souffrait il
y a quelques années d'une mauvaise
réputation et qui a même failli être
fermé aujourd'hui il est devenu un
établissement pilote en matière de lutte
contre la violence le personnel a été
renforcé et de nouvelles méthodes
d'encadrement ont été mises en place un
système qui fonctionne apparemment si
bien qu'il pourrait servir d'exemple la
NUG
alicebethular première règle arrivée à
l'URE vous êtes très largement en retard
allezy bonjour bonjour à
15 la grille du lycée professionnel
turgo se referme le retard à terre n'est
pas admis en cours compé pour absent et
toute absence doit être justifiée chaque
fois la famille est prévenue par
courrier ou par téléphone
oui bonjour Mame Pascal Thom CP lycé tur
à Roub je vous appelle parce que cé est
encore une fois pas là ce
matin première heure à l'appel il était
pas là deè heure mais l'élève est aussi
invité à la
discussion essaie de contacter désormais
les élèves directement pour savoir
pourquoi tu ne viens pas quelles sont
les raisons qui font que on essaie de
mettre en place quelque chose où l'élève
soit véritablement
acteur il y a 3 ans encore turgo était
le lycée le moins côté de l'Académie
lanterne rouge pour les résultats
champion pour la violence et les
dégradations aujourd'hui les bâtiments
ont été rénovés la surveillance
renforcée d'importants moyens ont été
affectés plus d'une centaine d'adultes
encadrent 450 élèves presque tous issus
de milieux défavorisés
là
c'est je dis que pour des jeunes en
rupture des jeunes en difficulté au
contraire l'exigence doit être majeure
une exigence une exigence intelligente
humaine comprise comprise non une
exigence j'allais dire autoritariste
ou écrasante
mais comprise par les jeunes avec qui on
travaille un principe responsabilisé un
moyen le dialogue une classe refuse
certaines activités en cours le problème
est aussitôt mis au débat entre élèves
professeurs et direction et là j'étais
un peu déçu quoi c'est dommage parce que
la plupart d'entre vous c'est vrai que
commeki on a vu au premier trimestre tu
t'es pris un carton dans certains cas
d'indiscipline grave c'est la sanction
Hassan a menacé un professeur et dégradé
des locaux reçu par le proviseur adjoint
il doit maintenant expliquer sa faute la
comprendre puis la réparer c'est ce que
N appinclusion d'accord ailleurs Hassan
aurait été exclu i la S est négociée et
finalement accepté l'élève
s'engage et j'accepté j'avais pas le
choix soit j'accepis les propositions
soit je pensais qu' discipline si je
pensais qu' discipline j'avais qu'une
chance d'être repris Hassan a endommagé
une classe il viendra travailler 3h
pendant ses vacances avec l'ouvrier
d'entretien ça permet aussi au élèves de
voir notre travail parce que c'est vrai
quand nous on fait les classes un encore
nettoi ils sont pas là donc ils savent
pas hein c'est toujours propr pour eux
hein donc là ça permet au gamin de voir
que c'est nettoyer une salle écr sur les
tables en cours les effectifs sont
limité à 24 élèves si besoin la classe
estdoublé ou alors l'enseignement est
renforcé dans certain cas une aide
éducatrice épaule le professeur et les
élèves parce que avoir 24 élèves dans
une classe et avoir tous les chutements
en même temps pose 20 20 questions en
même temps bah ça lâche en boule dans un
côté alors que d'avoir une aide
éducatrice ça nous aide dans un sens
comme ça peut l'aider aussi on peut
parler d'enseignement personnalisé oui
et différencié parce que bon les élèves
ont des niveaux tout à fait différents
donc on explique différemment pour
chacun des élèves des méthodes qui
portent leurs fruits aujourd'hui le taux
de réussite aux examen augmente à turgo
la violence est maîtrisée l'absentéisme
a été ramené à un niveau raisonnable
mieux encore la réputation du lycée est
en train de changer dans certaines
filières il y a aujourd'hui plus de
demandes d'inscription qu'il n'y a de
place
disponible qui faut le rappeler vous
êtes vous-même allé à la rencontre de ce
qu'on appelle les jeunes en difficulté
dans ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
cités c'était il y a quelques années à à
vous envelin que vous inspirent les
expériences comme celles que nous vons
de présenter voà c'est c'est très
encourageant
c'est ça casse justement cette sorte de
de tictac entre prévention d'un côté et
répression de
l'autre ceux qui sont pour la prévention
passent souvent pour des angéliques et
ceux qui sont pour la répression passent
pour des flics cogneurs je crois que il
faut retrouver une relation humaine avec
les je les parents ou est qu'il faut
responsabiliser comme certains
politiques le disent responsabiliser les
les parents quelque fois de faç sont
radicales oui mais c'estàd
que il
faut au mieux responsabiler les parents
mais mais mais il y a aussi des parents
qui sont dans des situations vous le
savez bien épouvantable le père a pas de
boulot la mère elle fait ce qu'elle peut
pour nourrir ses ses
homme voilà bon donc évidemment si si le
M m'a jamais vu son père travailler
effectivement quand on lui dit d'aller à
l'école mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'erreur à ne pas commettre
c'est c'est de tomber encore une fois
soit dans le gnannantisme soit dans dans
dans une sorte de de de
folie
répressive ce sont pas des délinquants
ontologiques et tout ce qui a été dit là
tout ce qui est montré là ça prouve que
quand il y a un dialogue quand il y a
une sorte de prise en compte de
l'individu sont c'est pas des
délinquants dans le ventre de leur mère
moi j'ai eu affaire à des types qui
était je vousure c'était pas des c'était
pas des enfants de cœur et il y avait
des coups de gueule et tout ça mais
c'était formidable parce que un respect
mutuel sans stor vous restez avec nous
on va parler de votre spectacle dans
quelques instants tout de suite
l'actualité sportive politique c'est
finià fin non on va parler de rugby
puisque vainqueur de deux grands schlems
consécutifs le 15 de France mettra
demain sa réputation en jeu face au pays
de Gall l'équipe de France pourra en
tout cas compter sur la star la star
montante du rugby français il s'agit de
Thomas casteniad après plusieurs
blessures le joueur est revenu
aujourd'hui à son meilleur niveau
portrait de ce sportif au multiples
talents portrait signé Denis Guerin et
manuel
Beck les enfants ne s'y trompent plus
ils en ont fait leurs joueur préférés à
24 ans Thomas castged a déjà tout gagné
le grand schlem avec l'équipe de France
mais aussi une coupe d'Europe et quatre
titres de champion de France avec le
Stade Toulousain à l'époque le jeune
Thomas ne s'est pas encore teint les
cheveux en blonds mais tout déjà réussi
à cet ingénieur qui trouve encore le
temps de monter sur les planches ou de
recevoir cette semaine le trophée Midi
Olympique du meilleur joueur de l'année
le garçon pourtant ne joue pas vraiment
les vettes moi j'aime pas trop tirer que
ce soit en bon ou en mauvais sortir un
individu d'un groupe le rugby représente
tellement l'esprit d'équipe et l' esprit
de de groupe que tirer un homme du lot
c'est c'est assez difficile ressortir un
joueur V l'au c'est parfois inévitable
castagned est bien placé pour le savoir
France Angleterre il y a 3 ans son drop
donne la victoire au 15 tricolor à 2
minutes de la fin même scénario il y a
un mois en Irlande la France est menée
au score mais castignen ne tremble pas
et réussit la pénalité qu' ne faut pas
manquer vous savez quand on est buteur
il faut être très fort mentalement si on
est pas fort mentalement quand on est
buteur c'est c'est pas les buts faciles
qu'il faut mettre c'est les buts
difficiles et Thomas il a il a cette
capacité là c'est de mettre les buts
difficiles le demi d'ouverture français
n'est pas seulement buteur plus que
d'autres il incarne le jeu à la
française fait d'improvisation et de
prise de risque l'an dernier par ses
coup d'œil et ses coup de rein il fut à
l'origine de la démonstration française
à Wembley face au Gallois 51 à0 castaged
l'alliance du talent et du
culot dans la vie je me pose pas trop de
questions je fonctionne à l'intuition et
et à l'envie ainsi va Thomas castagned
petit génie du rugby français qui
voudrait bien s'offrir un nouveau grand
schlem en attendant l'automne prochain
et la Coupe du
Monde des nouvelle présent de la course
à la voile a tour du monde en solitaire
avec Escal l'italien Soldini qui avait
secouru la Française ticier a été
gratifié d'une bonification de 24 he
quant à Marc ticelin il attend l'arrivée
dans les prochaines heures d'un m tout
neuf pour remplacer celui qui avait
cassé il y a quelques jours nous venons
de recevoir les premières images du
bateau de tircelin des images qui
permettent de comprendre la semaine que
vient de vivre le navigateur français
Alexandre Cara un peu comme un bateau
fantôme c'est le navire de Marc tircelin
qui émerge du brouillard de l'Atlantique
Sud c'était un dimanche le dernier jour
de février sous grémand de fortune une
voilure bricolé sur un M brisé le
solitaire malchanceux découvre à
l'horizon la silhouette des î malwin 4
jours aravant il était alors en tête de
la trè étape Marc tircelin est victime
d'un dématage après avoir colmaté une
voie d'eau il décide de rejoindre par
ses propres moyens porstanley sur les
îles mallowin pour réparer et continuer
la course à porstanley son équipe
technique l'accueille il est temps de
constater les dégâts par chance le
solitaire n'est pas blessé le coup j'ai
entendu craque donc je me suis dit tiens
c'est un craqu de plus et en fait tout
de suite très très peu de temps après il
y a la tête de main qui a traversé ici
alors normalement je suis assis ici moi
avec sur les ordinateurs le trou le Main
traversé juste là où j'aurais dû être
j'ai eu pas mal de chance j'étais juste
à un M en fait et il a traversé comme ça
il a défoncé la table là est soutenu
maintenant avec des Boutes mais il a
fait tomber la table à carte et arraché
la table à carte et il a été se s'arrêt
sur les Ponties qui est brisé là-bas
pour reprendre la mer le monoco a besoin
d'un nouveau Mâ fabriqué en urgence
celui-ci a quitté Londres hier soir par
avion il devrait arriver dans
l'après-midi à P Stanley la réparation
effectuée il faudra ticela encore 4
jours de mer avant d'atteindre Punta
deesté le terme de l'étape si
mathématiquement le Français a déjà
perdu Rand alone voilà un marin dont la
volonté peut forcer le respect en effet
sans tircelin la course en classe 1
serait déjà finie faute de
concurrents puis nous retrouvons notre
habité guib Bedos qui joue actuellement
les prolongations au Théâtre de la
Renaissance à Paris alors guedos vous
aimez bien jouer avec votre public c'est
pour cela que nous avons choisi de
donner la parole aux spectateurs qui
viennent vous voir vous allez constater
si vous ne le saviez pas déjà que votre
public est extrêmement divers je ne vous
en dis pas plus voici les les réactions
recueillies par Marie Jos J et BL
grenier à la sortie de votre
spectacle comment vous le trouvez bien
mais encore très bien mais encore
toujours très bien joue les
prolongations son public aussi
éclectique comme les sujets qu'il
abordent tout le monde en prend pour son
grade la fête des ma encore moi adieu je
reste je l'adore depuis que je suis
petit je le suis
depuis d'anné 30 ans que j'entends
ça humoriste j'aime bien et homme encore
plus parce qu'il a fait là au niveau des
son papier il a pasiné c'est important
avec l'un de mes filleuls congolais
brave Kip qui survit ici comme il peut
ni voleur ni dealer ni tueur non carleur
voyez carleur bon carleur j'en ai
d'ailleurs profité pour le faire bosser
au black à la maison non je blague je
blue il est assez sexy c'est vrai qu'il
a quelque
chose
possible c'est pas trop mon type et
vieill est très bien je l'aime je n'ai
vécu que pour les femmes mais comme
beaucoup d'adolescents de ma génération
je me suis d'abord énormément
masturbé des heectolitres de
improductif qui sont déversés dans les
canalisations de l'habitation familiale
je trouve très méchant donc j'aime bien
ce qu'il dit c'est un des rares comiques
qui balance des vérités un peu sur tout
le monde avant c'était un peu plus sur
la gauche maintenant c'est sur la gauche
sur la droite sur tout le monde donc
c'est génial voulez que je vous dise sur
la
droite à part réclamer une minute de
silence je vous pose la question ce
serait quoi laanti de Chirac c'est la
mairie de Paris c'est la mairie de Paris
ils ont tous tapé dans la caisse vouz
que je vous dise il pourra pas se caché
longtemps derrière ce nain de tibée
forcément grand couillon il dépasse on
voit que
lui arrête nos décideurs socialistes de
pleurer sur le malheur des Algériens et
des Algériennes en Algérie tout en
continuant de fournir un coup
d'expulsion quotidienne de la viande
fraîche au couteau des égorgeurs ça me
choque et j'aime ça donc c'est plutôt
plutôt bien pense que c'est pour ça
qu'on aime
bos000 c'est le siècle où je vais
décéder si ça se
trouve et ça ça
m'agace la seule chose qui me console
c'est qu'on va tous y
passer comment vous avez trouver
gibedos peut mieux faire toujours peut
mieux faire si vous aviez un message à
lui faire
passer
accroche-toi accroche-toi message de Guy
à Bedos on a l'impression que c'est une
question qui vous obsède la durée de
votre carrière vous dit 30 ans déjà 30
ans je rajoute un peu c'est un jeu c'est
un jeu c'est un jeu c'estd qu'en fait je
sens que pour beaucoup je
m'incruste depuis trop longtemps voilà
ils se disent mais enfin qu'est-ce qu'il
a pas mourir celui-là il est toujours là
il est à peu près en forme il est
énervant et donc il y a eu des
tentatives de certains de vos confrères
de la presse écrite de Me asbiner si je
dire sans succès ENF vous les avez
gratiné pas mal hein dans votre oui oui
oui voilà oui Mo moi je me PL pasot
pique hein euh c'est-à-dire que je me
sens un tout petit peu journaliste alors
ben je donne mon avis sur sur sur les
choses et et certains pensent parmi vos
confrères que c'est chasse garder et que
un sal Taban comme moi ne doit pas
s'aventurer sur leur terre donc voilà
mais ben je continue à le faire quand
même même quand vous ne parlez pas sur
scène de politique ou d'évolution de la
société comme vous l'avez fait avec nous
vous évoquez beaucoup le sexe est-ce que
vous ne seriez pas
obsédé parce qu' obséd c'est c'est une
question oui c'est une
réponse non je pas vraiment obsédé je
suis je suis intéressé intéressé par ces
choses je trouve que oui non ça ça reste
je trouve que ça reste une des une des
valeurs sûres finalement dans ce monde
tout fou le
camp l'amour l'amour avec un grand ta
qu'il faut pas oublier mais si c'est
accompagné du plaisir de la séduction et
cetera c'est pas mal hein ça ça compte
aussi ah je suis d'accord oui car vous
avez des des fiches sur scène je sais
que vous n'aimez pas cette question
est-ce que vous ce sont des antisages ou
pas franchement durant toute la soirée
je me suis demandé a-t-il son texte
écrit qu'est-ce qu'il y a dessus
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dessus bah il y a
non non il y a vraiment des des des
textes écrits ce que je dis c'est que si
j'avais des fiches blanches ça serait le
MIM
Marceau qui aurait peur de de trop de
mémoire mais euh non non j'ai des textes
écrits mais je les je les bouscule un
peu ces texte mais ça me sert
d'antisèche oui et ça me par que j'ai
parce que j'ai j'aborde beaucoup de de
sujets et puis puis quelqu foois je suis
obligé de glisser des sujets qui évolu
et cetera donc il vaut mieux que j'ai ça
pu puis c'est devenu maintenant c'est ça
fait partie du spectacle d'ailles vous
jou avec j'ai une question concernant
encore le spectacle il n'y a pas
d'entrac tout au moins il y a un entract
un petit peu particulier c'estàd que
vous obligez les gens à rester sur place
vous êtes sûr que c'est bien reçu ça bah
apparemment oui rest oui il pas eu de
plainte
non pas et puis Mar non mais en fait
c'est c'est c'est biologique ça m'a été
imposé par mon grand âge justement parce
que je me livre à une prestation
chorégraphique qui a oui qui qui a l'air
de plaire mais qui me souffle un peu et
donc je je ne pouvais pas enchaîner
directement alors je suis allé chercher
une chaise et puis j'ai décidé de faire
un rract et je reste presque une
demi-heure face au public où je papote
comme ça sur les sur les oui les les
faits du jour ou de la semaine bon et
bien reste avec nous on va vous proposer
une très agréable une fin de journal
animal pour ne pas dire bestial dans un
instant nous irons en Angleterre
découvrir que là-bas on prend des
assurances pour protéger des poules mais
tout de suite un reportage sur l'élevage
en France des mulets c'est très sérieux
reportage chez un dresseur avec
jean-ifff Perin Vincent
Maillard un peu hésitante ce sont ses
premiers pas dans le vigob de bagous 5
jours seulement que H mulle de 4 ans la
Bour cette jeune vigne un peu hésitant
Vincent son guide a rêvé de ses labours
des nuits entières retrouver les gestes
qu' on appris les frères pars ses
associés ses aînés aussi ils avaient une
mule jusqu'en 84 ils travaillaient avec
elle ils ont approuvé l'envie de Vincent
l'histoire d'acheter une mule à bagnoule
c'est à la fois pour renouer avec une
vieille tradition et en même temps pour
je dirais pour préparer l'avenir dans le
sens où c'est une belle alternative aux
techniques chimiques de de
désherbage et puis c'est vrai que sur
bagou ça correspond à une réalité parce
que on a quelques difficultés à faire
passer les engins qui
roulent
Sam m il l'a trouvé ici dans laariège
chez Olivier Courtiade le dernier
dresseur De Mul qui exerce en
France ce jourl il débourrait un mulet
désobéissant pour le compte d'un
particulier il a mois et dem pour lui
faire le
caractère 2 an de métier ça aigise le
coup
d'il laiss le filet
Remon là c'était la première fois qu'il
avait un mort et des guides donc
assouplissement de la bouche de la nuque
et
latéralendreincurver les chevaux sont
beaucoup plus crtif
et moins intelligent il Assimil moins
vite
plus de çaut que c'est un animal
intelligent et les hommes n'aiment pas
les êtres
intelligents peuent pas les soumettre
ça c'est bien tu vois il cède là il cède
de plus en plus et ça c'est bien et puis
il est il est sur trois pieds ça veut
dire qu'il est au repos ça ça me plaît
comme attitudech sont mort il est
détendu c'est bien sait que c'est fini
là il est il est parfaitement calme on
remonte c'est bon caressele et c'est bon
allez Olivier n'a jamais eu de tracteur
quand il a hérité de sa ferme de 20 he
moitié en PR en forêt il a choisi de
limiter les investissements un S de
gagner c'est aussi un S qu'on n pas
dépensé a-t-il l'habitude de dire sa
méthode pour dresser les animaux les
faire participer à tous les travaux de
la ferme charier le fumier deux fois par
jour labourer les quelques parcelles
cultivables débarder les f de sapin
abattu par la dernière neige il y a de
quoi faire de quoi faire voir aussi à
ces
stagiaires quand se tourne c'est qu'ell
a pas érieur dans les
chaînes
ses revenus sont modestes ils vient la
vente des animaux qu'il dressent des
mulets mais aussi quelques BS ses
clients des particuliers des metteurs en
scène de cinéma qui ont besoin
d'attelage et de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs j'ai passé un temps où
les seuls animaux que je dressais
servait au loisir uniquement et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que que ça
soit pour le débardage en forêt ou que
ça soit pour la l'agriculture
l'agriculture biologique en particulier
j'ai des demandes de plus en plus
nombreus qui sont qui sont doubles parce
qu'en fait il faut fournir et l'animal
qui convient et la formation pour le
pilote parce que c'est pas évident
surtout quand on sort d'un milieu urbain
et même quand on est un agriculteur d'un
certain âge c'est-à-dire jeune qui n'a
pas vécu les animaux de trait c'est pas
du tout évident de se remettre de
devenir animalier l'acceptation car
vivre avec des animaux à demeure leur
parler les soigner cela s'apprend une
tâche quotidienne quelquefois
fastidieuse que certains acheteurs
oublient régulièrement allez petit mulot
tu as eu ta sérence de carré sa thérapie
il faut leur rappeler Olivier le sait
bien lui qui vit avec eux toute
l'année bon on passe à présent des mules
aux poules une poule britannique qui
illustre bien l'immense passion que les
Anglais vouent aux animaux le
propriétaire d'un pub a assuré pour
20000 francs une poule qu'il considère
comme sa fille ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie l'histoire vrai elle nous
est raconté par Étienne
Lenart Maurice chevali aurait pu dédier
sa chanson à Violette la plus célèbre
des poules d'Angleterre depuis que son
propriétaire un patron de peuple de
lessex a dépenser 20000 francs pour
assurer son pipette le contrat précise
qu'il touchera 10 millions de francs en
cas de vol alors gros coup de
pub
violette fait désormais partie de notre
famille et je prie le ciel pour qu'il ne
lui arrive rien cette poule est
précieuse pour nous elle n'a pas de
prix des histoires comme celle-là
l'actualité britannique en regorge du
chien Zabi récompensé pour avoir perdu
25 kg en quelques semaines au chat
Humfrey locataire des gouttières du 10
downning suite la résidence du Premier
ministre et dont la disparition avait
entraîné une très violente campagne de
presse en passant par la cavalcadefiné
de de cochon promis à l'abattoir et qui
avait tenu en haleine tout le pays
pendant une semaine en Grande-Bretagne
les animaux sont des stars et on les
traite comme
tel un enlèvement est toujours possible
car violette comme d'autres animaux est
aujourd'hui devenue une star elle est
donc assurée contre l'enlèvement et nos
conditions d'assurance sont très
précises mais comme toutes les stars ils
ont aussi leurs humeurs Fernand le
faisant vient lui de faire les gros
titres parce qu'on l'a surpris vidéo à
amateur à l'appui en train de harceler
le facteur du village obligé à plusieurs
reprises de battre en retraite aux
dernières nouvelles le courrier n'est
plus distribué le village est en colère
et aucune assurance ne couvre les
facteurs contre les agressions de
faisant et autres
gallelinacés ça vaut bien la vache à
Jospin
hein moi j'adore les animaux mais il
faut pas que ça devienne pathologique
non plus ça vous afflige là bah oui non
mais parce que comment dire on peut
aimer les moi j'ai j'ai deux chat de
chiens ils sont je crois très bien
traités ils ont beaucoup de place à la
maison mais vous ne les avez pas assuré
non non et puis il y a pas une
canonisation comme ça de des animaux
c'est quand même ça prouve un dérapage
mental à C fort gubos merci d'être resté
en notre compagnie pendant tout long ce
journal je rappelle que vous êtes au
Théâtre de la Renaissance jusqu'au 10
avril merci beaucoup ça nous a fait
plaisir merci on termine par un mot de
la bse de Paris le CAC